If you want to know about all the time travel
mistakes and inconsistencies in Happy Death
Day 2U, then stick around to the end of this
video.
This video is sponsored by Shudder and their
new series, A Discovery of Witches.
This show has got witches, vampires, daemons
and haunted houses.
And these creatures are secretly living alongside
man, hidden in plain sight.
It’s based on the best-selling All Souls
trilogy and it’s got Teresa Palmer from
Hacksaw Ridge and Matthew Goode from Downton
Abbey and The Crown.
Season 1 is now out exclusively on Shudder
and Sundance Now and there are two more seasons
already on the way.
Check out the description for a 30-day free
trial.
Happy Death Day 2U opens with Ryan waking
up in his car filled with Hot Pocket wrappers
and walking down the street to go back to
the dorm on the morning of Tuesday the 19th.
This is just a few minutes before the final
scene of the first movie, where Ryan does
make a reference to having to sleep in the
car.
“She’s back?”
“Out.”
“I’m not sleeping in my car again, it
smells like hot pockets and feet.”
When Ryan gets into the dorm building, he
crosses through a student blowing a horn at
one of the dorm rooms.
This is the first time we’re seeing something
that is only heard in the first movie, every
time tree wakes up after the loop resets her
to Monday the 18th, this can be heard in the
distance.
“Shut up!”
“Oh hey!”
What is this, an early Smosh video?
“SHUT UP!”
So after getting kicked out of his room, Ryan
goes to the science building to check on his
invention, the Sisius Quantum Cooling Reactor,
nicknamed the Sissy for short.
Here, we learn that the machine has been eating
up a ton of power to operate, which is the
reason for all the power outages seen in the
first movie.
“Our tuition dollars at work.”
I don’t know why this machine would affect
the power in other buildings, because that’s
not really how electricity works, but maybe
it has more to do with the machine’s interdimensional
effects and less to do with power consumption.
There are a couple of fun set dec things I
noticed in the lab, like a little figurine
of Nicola Tesla, the guy who basically invented
the alternating current electricity system
we use today.
There are also some magazines on the table
called Zombie Power Magazine.
This director of the Happy Death Day films,
Christopher Landon also made a zombie movie
called Scouts Guide To The Zombie Apocalypse.
“Boom.”
After the school’s Dean tells Ryan they’ll
have to confiscate the machine, he wanders
around the science building trying to find
his fellow nerds, where he is killed by a
masked Babyface killer, causing his day to
reset to the beginning of Tuesday the 19th,
so he wakes up in his car, where we can see
his license plate reads “meco” which might
have something to do with his mechanical engineering
skills.
Ryan gets back to the dorm room and explains
what just happened.
He tells Tree and Carter that he feels like
he’s going through Deja Vu, which is exactly
what Tree said when she first experienced
the time loop in the first film.
“I’m totally having Deja Vu right now.”
“Oh, I have it all the time.
It’s supposed to mean, like, someone’s
thinking about you while they’re masturbating.
I have it at least five times a day.”
*sigh* Do you want to tell her or should I?
So they end up going after this new killer
with a baseball bat.
I’m sure the actress Jessica Rothe, who
plays Tree, appreciated having the bat in
her hands this time.
“I also really like the baseball bat one,
though that one, I did not like shooting,
but no, all of the deaths were really fun.”
“Why not?”
“Because, they hit me in the head with a
baseball bat…
Not a real one!
Not a real one.”
Unfortunately for her, the killer gets away
this time, so they head over to place that
Carter believes they’ll be safest from the
Baby mask killer…
The… basketball game… where literally
everybody has a baby mask.
The fans of this team really got clever with
their signs, nicknaming their stadium “the
cradle”, and coming up with slogans such
as “babies gonna deliver,” which is funny
because usually it’s the doctor who delivers
the baby, but at the end of this movie, its
the babies, delivering a big blow to the doctor,
Dr. Butler.
Tree also runs into Tim who she gives a thumbs
up when she notices him sitting next to this
guy in the stands.
This is a reference to her accidental discovery
that Tim is gay when trying investigate who
her killer is in the first movie.
But after the basketball game lets out, Babyface
comes after Ryan with a knife and ends up
chasing him into the storage area of the Bayfield
University merch store, where Tree knocks
out the killer with a basketball trophy.
“I had a little practice.”
“Well who is it?”
“Only one way to find out.”
Huh!
It’s old man Witherspoon from the graveyard!
And he would have gotten away-- oh no nevermind
it’s another Ryan.
So they go back to the lab again...
“Back to the lab again.”
...to try to send doppel Ryan back to his
own dimension, but inadvertently end up sending
Tree to another dimension, which I’ll be
calling Dimension B, only in this dimension
she’s still stuck in Monday the 18th, and
she’s understandably furious at Ryan for
sending her back.
This causes Carter to ask them if they know
each other.
Ryan says no, because this version of Ryan
has never met Tree, and Tree says yes, because
she doesn’t realize this is actually Dimension
B Ryan.
This is an inverse of something that happened
at the sorority lunch in Happy Death Day.
“Wait, you two know each other?”
“Yeah--”
“No.”
“We had a class together last year.”
As the day goes on Tree notices that this
dimension has many differences from her dimension.
Carter and Lori know each other, and by the
way, Lori is not evil now, Danielle and Carter
are dating because Danielle is seemingly nice
in this dimension.
For example, she recommends doing the Special
Needs Art Fair charity and she’s actually
excited about it in Dimension B, whereas in
Dimension A…
“I can say right now, there’s no way we’re
doing the special needs art fair again.”
There are still fundamental similarities between
the two dimensions though.
The power goes out at the same time, Lori
still covers a double shift for Jen at the
hospital,
“Doing a double for Jen.
She has the flu.”
And Tree still has a birthday lunch with her
father at the same time, only in this dimension
her mother is alive as well and she also attends.
The birthday cake that her dad brings out
looks identical to the cake that we see in
the video on Tree’s phone when she’s looking
back at the memories of her shared birthday
with her mom in the first one.
“Back to the lab again.”
Tree explains the situation to the nerds,
and Carter compares it to the events of Back
To The Future Part 2.
I guess Tree realllly makes an effort to stay
away from movies, because just like at the
end of Happy Death Day, Tree has no idea what
he’s talking about.
“You now what your little scenario reminds
me of?”
“What?
What’s that?”
“Groundhog Day.
The movie Groundhog day.”
"I don't know."
“With Bill Murray?”
“Who’s Bill Murray?”
Tree realizes one thing that doesn’t add
up in Universe B.
If Carter and Danielle are a couple, then
why does Carter take home Tree?
Why does she wake up in the dorm room in the
first place?
He tells her that he slept on Ryan’s bed
and he only took her home because he was afraid
she was going to choke on her own vomit like
Janis Joplin.
This is the same line Universe A Carter uses
in the first movie when accused of taking
advantage of Tree.
“No, you’re wasted last night, and I was
afraid you were gonna fall or choke on your
own vomit, like Janis Joplin.”
So they try running the Sissy machine again,
but it doesn’t work because the nerds don’t
have the right algorithms.
The rattle caused by the machine actually
knocks the clock off the wall, indicating
progress has been halted.
Basically, there’s no way for them to test
all the algorithms in one day, and when the
day resets, they won’t know which ones have
already been tested.
That leaves them with only one option.
Tree must memorize each equation, and use
her Reading Steiner ability, or her ability
to carry her memories whenever time is reset,
to let them know which algorithms have already
been tested.
That leads us to a suicide montage filled
with outdated memes like Nyan Cat, drinking
bleach and even FML.
A couple of Tree’s self kills contained
some fun references, like the poster on the
skydiving plane that says “like a leaf.”
You know.
Because her name is Tree.
And when she throws herself into the woodchipper,
it says “tree removal service on the side
of it.”
You know.
Because her name is Tree.
I love to think about what happens in all
of these dimensions that Tree dies in.
Just think about it, in one of these universes,
there is a reality where Carter and his girlfriend
Danielle are just sitting outside, and all
the sudden Danielle’s half naked best friend
falls out of the sky and splats on the sidewalk
in front of them.
And they have to deal with that for the rest
on their lives and they never know why.
But also during Tree’s many deaths, she
discovers that Lori actually seems to be the
victim in this world, so she spends some of
her time trying to figure out who the killer
is, because, remember, in this one, Lori isn’t
evil.
During one of the suicides, Tree jumps from
the clock tower and there’s a cool transition
to her landing in Carters bed to start the
loop over again, it was very similar to my
favorite death from the first movie.
Eventually, they figure out the correct equation,
and Ryan tells Tree she can choose between
closing the loop and staying in Dimension
B or closing the loop behind her as she goes
back to Dimension A. So she has the decision
to make between her mother and Carter.
Past, or future.
And there’s one thing you might have missed
that I think is the key to her making that
decision.
When she has the heart to heart talk with
her mother at the motel room, she asks her
Mom, what would you do if you had to choose
between Dad and someone else you really cared
about?
Her mom says she’d probably choose Tree’s
father, because without him, she never would
have had Tree.
I’ll try to refrain from any jokes about
him having “the seed for Tree”, but I
think this is what makes Tree’s decision
to go back to her own dimension make sense.
She’s not just choosing Carter over her
mom, she’s choosing all the possible future
memories that she and Carter might share.
Let’s not forget this line from the first
movie.
“His name’s Carter.
No, we did not have sex, but if I finally
make it through this day somehow, I’m gonna
have his babies.”
So in order to stop them from closing the
time-loop and to reset the day all in one
go, she crashes her car into the power distribution
box thing, and decides to give it one more
go.
She says goodbye to everyone from Dimension
B, where she learns that Danielle was actually
cheating on Carter with Nick, who if you don’t
remember, was Danielle’s crush in the first
one who Tree made out with at a party.
“It’s fine, you can make it up to me later.”
“What?”
“Don’t ‘what’ me!”
“You know exactly what you’re doing Tree.”
If we can pause for one second for my personal
opinion even though I’m not supposed to
have one…
One thing that kind of bothered me, was that
Tree never tells Carter B that his girlfriend
is unfaithful.
She helps out Lori, she gives advice to everyone
else, but she kind of leaves him hanging.
“Back to the lab again.”
So they get everything figured out, and just
as they’re about to send Tree back home,
the dean bursts in and takes away their time-travel
machine.
There are some issues with that, but I’ll
come back to it later.
So the gang needs to come up with a plan to
steal the machine back, they use Danielle,
who is an aspiring actress in this universe,
to distract the Dean, while they carry out
their plan.
Meanwhile, Tree has one more errand to run
in Universe B. She runs back to the med building
to save Lori from the killer, who she has
figured out is Dr. Butler, but there’s one
thing she didn’t guess -- his wife is also
one of the baby masked killers.
In Happy Death Day, Dr. Butler goes behind
his wife’s back to sleep with Tree, but
in the new universe, it’s Lori, which is
why the only time Tree was targeted in Universe
B was when she tried to protect Lori.
Also, this is very similar to the original
ending that was cut from the first movie,
which Christopher Landon explained in the
Q&A.
Roll it
“The original ending of the movie that we
shot, Tree survives the fight and then wakes
up in a hospital and then the Doctor kind
of rushes everybody out because she needs
a rest, and then this nurse comes in, and
starts to put something into Tree’s IV line,
and then she says, ‘oh no, no, you’re
not supposed to be doing that, and the nurse
pulls her mask down and reveals that it’s
Gregory’s wife, and she’s basically like
**** you.
And then she kills her.”
So it’s interesting to see that ending kind
of found a home in the sequel.
But there are some issues with the ending,
and when you’re dealing with time travel,
these things tend to come up.
At the very beginning Ryan passes by the trumpet
player in the hall, which as I mentioned,
is heard every morning on the 18th.
However, when Ryan gets to dorm room, he sees
this unfold, which is Tuesday the 19th, which
is after Tree killed Lori and got out of the
time loop.
I went back to the first Happy Death Day to
see if the trumpet is also played on the morning
of the 19th, and it is not.
“Oh hey, you’re up”.
Also, the whole thing with Ryan encountering
another version of himself isn’t consistent
with anything that happens for the rest of
the movie.
For example, when Tree is sent to Dimension
B, she never encounters Tree B and the nerds
tell her that the event likely caused Tree
B to be sent to another dimension altogether.
I also didn’t really get what the point
was of introducing a second Ryan, or having
Ryan A go through the time loop at all at
the beginning of the movie, because when Tree
returns to dimension A at the end, it never
shows them solving the second time loop, unless
the math that the nerds from Dimension B used
somehow solved all time loops in all dimensions,
but that wouldn’t make sense because then
some other Bayfield Students in some far superior
dimension could have just solved everything
without Tree A ever having to do anything.
So by all logical means, when Tree A gets
back to Dimension A, they should still have
to solve the issue of Ryan continually resetting
Tuesday the 19th, unless he’s saving that
for the third movie.
But that doesn’t seem to be the case because
the mid-credits sequence suggests that the
next movie will revolve around Danielle being
tested as a time loop experiment by the DARPA
agent Isaac Parker, which in itself doesn’t
make any sense because they would run into
the same problem that the Bayfield nerds had
in trying to figure out the correct algorithm
to close the time loops, an issue they were
only able to solve because Tree had the Reading
Steiner ability and she was somehow able to
remember every single equation that they tested
-- which, by the way presents a problem of
it’s own because Tree’s body started to
deteriorate in the first Happy Death Day and
she only dies 11 times in that.
In Happy Death Day 2U, it shows her killing
herself about five times I think it was, we’ll
have to ask Dead Meat, but she’d also have
to have way more off-screen deaths in order
to afford her the time to memorize all of
those equations… unless of course she just
has a photographic memory that conveniently
doesn’t work when she gets too drunk.
Now to be fair, she did do a similar thing
in the first movie when she was able to recall
everyone on her suspects list every day, but
that’s still considerably less information
than the equations.
But anyways, back to Danielle.
The DARPA agent was going to use her as a test subject,
but they would have no way of tracking the
progress of their experiments unless Danielle
remembers everything from each day, and relays
them the information each time she comes though,
something I have a hard time believing she
would ever agree to or be capable of.
But all of that aside, there just seem to
be some inconsistencies with Dimension B.
Like for example, there is one morning where
Tree wakes up and doesn’t interrupt Carter
B, and he goes on to ask her if she remembers
his name like the does in the first one…
but wait they should already kind of know
each other in Dimension B. He’s dating Danielle,
who is best friends with Tree in this dimension
and when Danielle comes up to the table she
acts like it’s completely normal for Carter,
Tree, Ryan, Samir and Anna to be hanging out.
Then there’s the fact that the last play-through
of Dimension B ends with Dean Bronson and
the two security guys coming to confiscate
the Sissy machine one day early, and while
that could be explained by the fact that he
might have just noticed the lights on the
fritz again and decided to put and end to
it, he specifically says that he told them
not to power it on again, which he never did
in Dimension B, because Tree never reached
Tuesday the 19th in that dimension.
But the real question we need to figure out…
the thing that could make or break all of
what I just said is… does anyone actually even care
besides me?
"Back to the lab again."
Big thanks to A Discovery of Witches on Shudder
and Sundance Now, for sponsoring this video.
This show follows a modern day witch named
Diana Bishop who accidentally discovers an
ancient text known as Ashmole 782, and when
word gets out about it, the entire community
of creatures basically comes after her -- including
this guy, a vampire who not only wants the
book, but has a craving for her blood.
She’s also quite interested in him, because
she’s a historian, and he’s been alive
practically forever and experienced historical
events first hand.
This series takes a more realistic approach
to witches, vampires and demons and there
are just a ton of twists and turns along the
way.
I’d definitely recommend checking it out
-- plus the soundtrack is certifiable bop.
If you want to watch it you can catch it exclusively
on Shudder and Sundance Now -- just use my
promo code for a 30-day free trial of either
service.
Shudder is the premium streaming service for
fans of the horror and thriller genre.
Guess what?
That’s you.
Shudder has the largest and fastest growing
human curated selection of the most thrilling
and dangerous content.
Sundance Now has award winning movies from
every genre including drama, comedy, true
crime and more; even including foreign language
and documentary features, all streaming commercial
free, it offers an extensive array of entertainment
hand picked by acclaimed filmmakers and cultural
icons for a passionate and intellectually
curious audience such as yourselves.
So here’s what you gotta do.
Head over to discoveryofwitchestv.com and
use promo code: 'czsworld' for a free 30-day trial
of Shudder or Sundance Now.
And remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for
new horrors every week, ring that deathbell
for notifications and I’ll see you in the
next one.
Assuming, we both survive.